- Whoop, whoop, Evan
Carmichael is in the house.
Wow, oh my God.
I did a review of his book Your One Word
and that is amazing that
he is on Livestream.
Evan's got like six
hundred billion followers.
That is so cool.
His book was so good, The One Word,
my one word was inspire
because I want to inspire people
to read books and travel the world.
What you want to do is see the book
review of Your One Word.
Go check that video out on my channel.
But also check out his videos.
What is the one word
that defines who you are
and what you stand for?
In today's video, I'm
going to be reviewing
Your One Word by Evan Carmichael.
Evan's got 700,000 people
following him on YouTube.
When I did the book review,
I'm sure you have like
650,000 people following you.
Yeah, #believe, that is Evan's one word.
You can use that in so many ways.
Like he says in the book,
words that are used the most
are usually the best words.
I'm super grateful and honored and humbled
Evan's in my Livestream.
It's actually taken me aback a little bit.
It all started with books for me.
I didn't go traveling,
I was out of shape,
I wasn't doing well in school,
and books really started that for me.
I started to read and I
started to expand my mind,
reading books like Your One
Word by Evan Carmichael.
These kind of books have helped me
to think in a way which is very different
from the mainstream so
I want to spread that message.
Okay, so Evan says, "Spread the mission.
People would love to hear
your inspired journey
and want to be apart of it.
Make them feel like they're
on the journey with you."
Yeah, that is 100%, 100% true.
That's what I'm trying
to do here with you guys.
I want you guys to come
on this journey with me,
traveling and also reading
lots of cool books.
Evan, actually this is
a good question for you,
one thing I'm not so
much worried about, but
one thing I have to think about is
when I go to New Zealand,
I'm obviously going to have to find a job
so I can support myself but
do you have any ideas of any ways for me
to be able to work from my laptop
or anything like that
would be really useful.
Is Evan still in the building?
Let me know if you're
still in the building Evan.
But thank you so much for
hoping into my stream.
Evan's still here.
Evan, do you have an opportunities for me
working for you remotely?
Because I remember in the book,
you said that your team works for you
from, um, remotely and
actually traveling the world.
I remember that clearly because
you had a quite young team and
they wanted to go traveling.
If you have any opportunities or
if you know any ways for me to
make money while I'm on the go
so I can support my travels, let me know.
(typing)
That's interesting, yes.
It depends on what value you can bring.
It's all about value.
That's all from Evan.
Thanks so much for dropping
in this Livestream.
Go ahead and pick up the wife.
You don't want to be late for her.
You don't want to be late.
Thanks for dropping in Evan.
See you in a bit.
Guys, Evan -
I'm - I'm going to say it in the comments.
Oh my God guys Evan.
He is so successful.
Yeah, so that -
I can't believe that just happened to me
on my first ever stream.
Evan has like a reach
of millions of people
around the world and he's done
what I've wanted to do so
that fact that you
dropped into my Livestream
is incredible.
Oh my God.
I mean, it's crazy, absolutely crazy.
What kind of value can
I bring to him guys?
I mean, he will be able to -
He's the kind of guy who can
offer so much opportunities
(typing)
(laughter)
Evan, oh that is so funny.
I bet he's still watching this as well.
So he said he's left.
I hope I said some really nice things.
I'm sure I did.
He's probably still watching now.
"Yes, you only said nice
things, Jayesh, don't worry."
So this has been so much fun.
And the funny thing is that
so I was shitting myself before I came
on this Livestream.
I was so nervous because it's all unedited
and I've never done
anything like this before.
And I didn't think anyone was going to
pop into this conversation.
I thought it was just going
to be me talking to myself.
So it just goes to show you that if
you do the things that
scare you, you get rewards,
and what's happened?
We've had 20-25 people, all friends,
get into conversations talking about
a really cool topic
and then having someone
like Evan pop in is just a bonus.